everybody I hope everyone's having a
fantastic
Wednesday I think it's Wednesday holy
crap I don't even know what day it is
I've been trying this whole like having
guests on as though I'm an actual
professional media personality with an
actual factual real show thing and
that's precisely why I had three arrows
on yesterday and you guys love that so
today without further ado I'm gonna
bring on David Pakman you guys might
know who he is he's the host of the
David Pakman show on DirecTV and Dish
Network over two hundred radio and TV
stations and on YouTube and also david
has a podcast he used to be on the TYT
Network as well so I'm gonna call him
right now once again and have him come
on immediately there was a lot of like
things that I was trying out all right
um David can you hear me all right
perfect let's see let's see if I totally
mess this up or not okay let's see
because I whenever I do the full screen
thing with these videos I just lose I
don't know why I just like lose
everything
it is very hard everyone here at least
on my twitch knows that I am just
incapable of handling technology
appropriately okay but it looks good you
look good we can see you let me adjust
your volume your audio levels and all
that all right thank you all right
perfect
cool cool all right David I don't really
know what we were gonna talk about
because a lot of people after a lot of
people kept sending me your Jesse Lee
Peterson interviews which were excellent
obviously I mean so I don't I don't know
I don't know what we would actually talk
about I feel like you and I agree on a
lot of things I guess maybe like social
democracy and like why what you think is
like why you think social democracy is a
better alternative than socialism maybe
we can get into that later but most
importantly I just wanted to ask you why
you're a children of the lie and child
of the lie a child of the lie yeah
because you oppose the great white hope
which oh my god man that guys [ __ ]
nuts holy [ __ ] yeah I used to take it
really seriously when I'd be on his show
I think the for I've been on three times
I think the first time I was kind of
like really taking it seriously and like
researching the topics they gave me and
then I realize like he will just say
whatever enters his mind and he'll force
you to answer like unfair questions kind
of like you actually had to deal with a
politican I would say just for
inappropriately framed questions that
people demand yes or no answers to and
so now when I appear with them I just
don't care what he says I just will if I
just want to stare at him when he asked
a question and not say a word I'll do it
and he'll just go on to another question
no that was dude that was so awesome oh
my god people are already [ __ ]
there's two people that constantly get
mentions in my in my twitch chat you're
one of them because of the Jesse Lee
Peterson interview the last one that you
did and your hair was looking excellent
in that Kyle kolinsky holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude I mean we're gonna have a monsoon
too but Jesus Christ like I mean it's
great it's great that like there's a
there's a coalition on the Internet of
like a lot of people who are
left-leaning or more progressive voices
and it's awesome but Jesus Christ the
kolinsky fanboys are annoying yours are
not yours are great but what do Kyle's
do that Sony they're just constantly
they're like what are you gonna have
Kyle on Hassan when are you gonna have
Kyle on a song like when I was debating
Ann Coulter people were like people
wouldn't shut up about why [ __ ] why
Ann Coulter did not debate Kyle like
they that's all they cared about they
were like you have to get an answer to
this question it doesn't matter if you
destroy her in debate or in or win any
w's in the marketplace of ideas or
whatever the [ __ ] people say all that
matters is an answer to the question why
did Ann Coulter runaway from colic
elinsky did you get a chance to ask her
I did she did not answer any of my
questions she used to look at me both on
stage and also off stage she refused to
acknowledge me as a human being or as a
peer I think she was like shaking a lot
too it was kind of a sad it was kind of
it's kind of a sad sight if I'm gonna be
honest but the only time she responded
to anything was when I was trying to
make small talk with her just trying to
like defuse the tension a little bit
maybe like
kind of get a better perspective of like
who this person is who is like almost
single-handedly responsible not
single-handedly but like one of the most
evil media figures partially responsible
for for paving the way for other I hate
this term but like other fire brands and
in provocateurs like Milo innopolis and
Tommy Lauren and now there's so many
different like fascist variations of
them out there but right if she paved
the way for so many of these people I
just wanted to understand like what she
is like in real life and like whether
she believes all this stuff never
responded to any questions I was just
like oh hey you chew nicotine gum like I
do as well with nicotine gum are you
chewing and she didn't even look at me
she could deep breath and just said the
childproof kind and that was the only
thing that she answered I don't know if
we're supposed to say kind of like what
happens behind the scenes at politican
but I happen to be waiting for the
talent shuttle when she showed up and
the the energy that came off of her and
just the way she was talking to
politican staff and said just like
everything about her was just vile oh
yeah um she like openly is like
anti-union it's kind of weird there's
like Union employees all around her we
were talking about that she was just
like so it was just weird
it was kind of weird but like I was at a
Fox affiliate so of course like there
were a lot of there were a lot of older
ladies and gentlemen that work behind
the scenes there that were absolutely
they were just floored they were so
excited that Ann Coulter was there yeah
so you know they were like surrounding
her it was really weird and they kind of
almost like saw me as like this young
child who's coming on and and and
talking to their to their icon you know
this person who's like defending their
rights by spreading I guess a more
acceptable form of like white
nationalism for approximately past like
two three decades almost but I thought
that I heard from people we both know
that there
when you go places that you also get a
swarm of people around you oh I mean
yeah but those are like those are cool
people and like-minded individuals
they're not there my fans are awesome
and Coulter's fans not so awesome
because I'm sure they're like-minded to
her no no of course of course I'm
obviously joking not really I don't
think I have like yeah I mean there's
definitely people that come up to me
when I'm in public but that's not like I
wouldn't say it's the norm oh I wouldn't
say like I get swarmed all the time you
know what I mean
maybe it was it actually so this was
Erin why sake who was telling me the
story it might have been last year at
politic on or maybe VidCon I don't know
if you've been to VidCon yeah I said
that when he walks around with you that
it's the ladies and the gentlemen
everybody's just going crazy
yeah Politico is like our conference so
like that's why but this year I didn't
even get a chance to really talk to a
lot of people because like there was a
lot more there was a lot more security
detail there it was like a lot it was
just very serious like III didn't even
get an opportunity to like walk around
and like talk to people or anything like
that this year I got what were you
advised not to walk around yeah oh
really
see nobody advised me other than like so
like behind the scenes I was talking to
a couple a couple people from TYT who
were like yeah I'm a little skittish
about some of the some of the audience
and I kind of felt the same way but then
somehow after one of my panels everybody
disappeared like Ana went to watch your
debate with charlie kirk and sam cedar
was gone I don't know Bakari sellers
disappeared Kyle kolinsky disappeared
and I ended up kind of like pinned up
against the wall all of mice people but
if anybody had not been nice there was
nobody around I ended up taking a couple
hundred pictures which was great but at
any point anybody could have could have
not had the best intentions and I was
just completely abandoned by my fellow
panelists oh yeah oh that's yeah that
happens that happens sometimes you gotta
be you gotta be watchful for that I mean
honestly it's not I don't know most of
the people that come up to me at VidCon
or political
these sort of conferences like public
facing stuff that we do are nice there
are yours always like challengers who
will do the debate me coward but in real
life but given the fact that I'm also
six foot four it's like a lot more
difficult for them to like actually do
that to my face and they then it is on
the Internet
when you know normally when they do it
on the internet it's anonymous so they
can just like spread whatever kind of
[ __ ] falsehoods or Nazi [ __ ] do
they want to say but in person it's like
a little bit more difficult but yeah I
I've I usually III I rarely ever have
like negative confrontations in public
like very rarely yeah same here I mean
everybody who comes up to me has been
nice and there was one guy who said can
you explain to me the difference between
socialism and social democracy and I
said well we'll only one of them is
actual socialism and he was just kind of
like satisfied with that and he walked
away I was like oh yeah that's
interesting
and they sat through the entire panel
about it which was weird yeah oh so that
was what your wait wasn't your sorry
should we be socialist as one of them
that was the fake news one was kind of
unfair because the only right winger was
roping roaming millennial fascist [ __ ]
by the way like if I'm not mistaken
right and it was kind of like everybody
was ganging up on her because she was
admittedly saying things we all
disagreed with but it felt very
one-sided well I feel like fake news is
by and large fairly one-sided like the
representation of what the right-wingers
assume is fake news on the left is not
actually not actually fake news that's
it's just like it's usually either
improperly ramming like it's it's within
the boundaries of like reasonable
boundaries of improper framing that
happens every now and then for sure um
or and by the way that happens to like
people to the left of the of the center
as well usually if you have more and
more progressive policies like Medicare
for all for example there's improper
framing in the way that they tackle that
issue and they're covering it as well
it's just like usually a protectionist
approach the status
but beyond that it's never it's rarely
ever like Seth Rich was murdered by
Hillary Clinton here's why
like the [ __ ] amount of coverage that
like Sean Hannity for example is
extended to to conspiracy theories of
that nature is is not even comparable on
the on the left well during the panel
David Brock from Media Matters was on
the panel and you know you could say
what you want about him but he shy away
from just telling it the way he sees it
and the first time that the that Sally
cone the moderator went to him he just
said listen let's not pretend that this
fake news thing is just like a phenomena
that is out there it exists almost
exclusively on the right none of you
people can name a single major fake news
story related to the 2016 election that
was perpetrated perpetuated by by the
left this is mostly a right-wing problem
and there were a bunch of people in the
front row like with the with the Trump
hats and wearing an American flag stuff
who just immediately started jeering but
nobody actually was able to name like a
prominent left-wing fake story yeah like
they'll usually they'll usually use
examples like I said we're we're like
media's of course capable of [ __ ] up
right and there are plenty of instances
where where they do end up like framing
the wrong person or whatever or they
don't do their due diligence but they
immediately they immediately I mean
there's there's ethics in journalism
right so they immediately make up for it
they they although they'll like either
edit the story or issue a correction and
apologize like this sort of stuff
happens on the left lot it kind of
happens on the right as far as like Fox
News goes but it definitely does not
happen on any of the alternative
platforms on the right that that reach
beyond Fox News like anything beyond the
borders of Fox News like they never
issue Corrections and they as a matter
of fact they weaponize fake news and
it's not just necessarily framing it's
it's literally just like dissemination
of fake information yeah and by almost
by definition like if you know it so the
whole correction thing came up during
the debate or the discussion and almost
by definition if you are in Corrections
it's almost guaranteed you're not a fake
news outlet like that that's what actual
journalistic outlets do which is when
they get something wrong
the facts they issue a correction and
it's made very clear that that's what
they did like it was crazy because you
know how they shift the goalposts and
actually this happens I've seen some of
your debates where the goalposts get
shifted on you oh yeah first the
conversation was just like what is fake
news
where does fake news come from how can
we fight fake news and then the
conversation was shifted by some guy in
the audience into you know when I see
media outlets issuing too many
Corrections I label them fake news and
it's like no you don't understand the
first thing about it because big news
does an issue Corrections the entire
story is fake like by definition if they
issued a correction they would say we
retract the entire story and they don't
do that yeah I mean again one side is I
mean I guess we there are definitely
alternative
there are definitely alternative outlets
on the left as well now that I think
about it that that definitely
disseminate misinformation but they're
not on any sort of mainstream platform
and they're not even necessarily there
on the fringes of the left usually in
like yeah okay yeah and I don't even
think that they are fake news they're
what I call like news repackages and
they repackage the biased and kind of
like slanted or incomplete way but
they're not coming up with stuff that's
the equivalent of like Hillary on a
respirator yeah yeah you know what
you're right yeah it's right it's never
like I guess the mainstream example
again like I said that goes beyond like
just framing is is the fact that you
have panelists on on fox news every
night talking about like whether the
Honduran Caravan has leprosy you know
what I mean like whether the immigrants
that are coming from Guatemala are
bringing like measles or like this new
kind of viruses that these new kind of
viral infections that we don't have
vaccinations for or whatever or not
that's [ __ ] mind-boggling I mean the
president is talking about Middle
Easterners being a part of the caravan
first of all is that even a problem
whether there are Middle Easterners like
he's not even saying like terror cells
or anything he's just saying like Arabs
basically brown people different shades
of brown and then like it that's again
that's [ __ ] fake news dude you can't
just like
mention that without any sort of basis
whatsoever so yeah I think it's totally
fair for the left though to say like on
my show are what we we say our sources
for stories and I won't use like not to
call anybody out but I I don't use
certain websites like I don't use Ross
story as a source for my news because
Ross story rarely is doing like original
reporting they're often just like
rewriting something that's been reported
by somebody else so I just don't don't
use that as a source for a story that
doesn't mean that the it's fake news it
just means it's not up to this
journalistic standards that we would use
if we're saying here's a commentary
based on something that happened here
are the facts but that doesn't mean that
they're perpetuating the type of stuff
that we see on the right yeah I mean the
same thing goes in in order to like move
this conversation segue into like the
second thing I kind of wanted to talk
about it like a a similar thing also
happens with inciting violence I feel
like we there's this there's this really
desperate but very deliberate effort on
the right to try to pinpoint any
fraction of violence that they possibly
can on like left-wing outlets or or just
like liberal media to try to make it
seem as though there is like this equal
playing field where both sides are also
perpetuating violence at a similar rate
or using this same kind of like militant
language or violent language to describe
certain things and and that to me that's
very frustrating I don't know what your
perspective is on this but yeah yeah so
listen I mean first of all if the left
is if left-wing media are hinting at
violence at the same rate that
right-wing media hint at violence the
left is failing big time because almost
75% of political violence in the u.s. is
perpetrated by the right so straight-up
like if if you're left and right are
both trying to get people to become
violent in the real world the left sucks
at it because almost none of the
political violence in the u.s. is coming
from the left that's number one but even
even beyond that I mean when you think
about some of the if somebody emailed me
the other day
said David the left perpetuates violence
like when Bernie said that if people
can't get health care a ton of people
will die and like death is violent
understand the idiocy of that argument
so he's literally pointing out that some
people can't afford care so they lie
because they die because they have no
health care that's not advocating
violence that's saying people sometimes
die in the world and I want to stop it
you know that that's the level that the
debate is operating on or they'll say
and Tifa through a bike lock once and
steve scalise that's like their big
example now yeah but even with the Steve
Scalise thing like you can't you you can
never actually [ __ ] claim with a
straight face that Bernie Sanders is
ever incited violence or even has used
like the he's the most like he's too
chill in my opinion I think he should be
more aggressive with the with his
messaging every now and then when he
when Maxine Waters for example came out
and said like we should confront people
wherever they are and I think this was
like controversial even on the left
because the left loves to [ __ ] eat
itself alive and some people were like
yeah that is violent and even like the
Democratic Party kind of straight away
from that messaging and was like this is
bad
Maxine Waters and they didn't defend her
which I had an issue with like I didn't
find that to be a violent I didn't find
that to be violent rhetoric at all I
thought that was you know confront
people in positions of power and help
them understand or make them understand
the the consequences of their of their
decisions at the legislative level like
this is this is what what else are we
supposed to do at this point you know
what I mean if they're not listening to
you if neither party is listening to you
and this extends of the Democrats as
well what are you supposed to do it's
not violence it's getting them to
respond to you do you know what I mean
yeah absolutely and and the other thing
you kind of mentioned which is really
important it like the Steve Scalise
example to go back to that there's no
overarching narrative that can be
pointed to from the establishment left
or from Democrats or from whoever that
would follow to
ooh shooting steve scalise we're like
we're currently seeing from the
administration it's like you're seeing
these sort of thinly veiled wink wink
nod nod to white supremacists and
anti-semites and so on and those are the
groups that are being activated and are
actually committing acts of real-world
violence you're seeing the attacks on
media and you've got actual media people
being yelled at needing extra security
when they just cover political events
like you-you-you there's a direct line
there that just simply doesn't exist
with something like Steve Scalise or an
Tifa yeah like we don't necessarily but
I guess something that would be similar
is if we had like eco-terrorists out
there or something you know what I mean
if like which we basically haven't since
the 60s and 70s we had like militant
leftists who were like no we're gonna go
in like bomb oil rigs in order to stop
their production which by the way I am
of course not advocating for that
absolutely and and like there's no
there's no equivalent to that even when
you look at like Planned Parenthood's
and whatever or like or like wellness
women's wellness centers what is it the
number is like 40 for women's wellness
centers have been bombed or 40 and
multiple people have died because they
work at like Planned Parenthood's in
[ __ ] since 1976 and and then you try to
make this like false equivalency like
well um some people were mean to me one
time because I was wearing a mag ahead
and that is ridiculous that's a
preposterous comparison and what's
really frustrating to me on top of
everything else is and maybe you and I
will disagree on this I think that
liberal media is also partially to blame
because of their [ __ ] hand wringing
over what's going on with all of this
violence why are we so divisive kind of
rhetoric when the answer is very obvious
only one side is is perpetuating or
perpetrating this kind of violence and
what liberal media's argument um the
majority of outlets like including CNN
will have panelists on and and will
usually cover this from a both sides
conversation and I'm of course firm your
leg even Chuck Schumer who alluded
fact that like there was some form of
equivalence between between like George
Soros getting a mail bomb to a
congressman a Republican congressman
office being vandalized that was on that
was I think the Monday before the the
when George Soros like originally got
the first packages like the first mail
bomb now that's when that first came out
and in the coverage for what I've seen
at least has usually been like well this
violence is really terrible
why are we so divided we need to they
it's just more of a focus on the
division and rather not who's causing
that division that devices yeah if I had
seen it that way I would agree with you
I just haven't seen it I I really seen
I've seen Democratic politicians do a
little bit of the both side stuff it
order it seems like not inflame people
more which we could debate whether
that's a good strategy or not cuz people
seem pretty inflamed already but I
haven't really seen left left-wing media
play that game I mean everybody I've
seen has been pretty clear like the
violence is almost exclusively coming
from one side the violent rhetoric is
almost exclusively coming from one side
and the blame is like pretty damn clear
as to where it lies yeah no I guess I
was referring more so to to like having
politicians on and are like platforming
politicians that holding them without
actually questioning their word when it
comes to the sort of stuff and even like
having right-leaning speakers or
right-wing speakers on to talk about the
corporate media is scared of being
accused of bias I was referring to
liberal like mainstream media which
would be still regarded as like liberal
I don't have problems i I think you got
to revisit that I don't know well you
they win when you just say that regular
media is and I think CNN mostly has like
a pro corporate bias and they they
follow I mean I think there's no doubt
that people like Don Lemon and some
others have taken maybe a more one-sided
approach to the president but remember
that the president has attacked a lot of
those people individually which is also
kind of like uncharted territory yeah
well the
why I say that is because again I think
this is you or you and I like have a
slight divergence but the reason why I
consider mainstream media to be liberal
is because like I still consider to be
like liberal capitalist therefore still
like somewhat left-leaning but still
rather conservative across the board
that's the reason why I would not
designate them as like left-leaning or
leftist but I but I don't have a
somewhat more liberal because they're
socially progressive I guess technically
I don't know if they are I mean I guess
that would be like has did CNN for
example like advocate for the Supreme
Court decision that made same-sex
marriage bans illegal I don't know that
was kind of like one of the big social
issues are they advocating for abortion
being legal I don't I don't really hear
that like I know that they they have
different panelists with different
opinions but I just don't see that when
I watch it and I immediately don't watch
that much I definitely see that bias on
MSNBC but I don't I don't know that I
see it on CNN oh yeah MSNBC is
definitely way more
I mean MSNBC is like openly subjective
right I would say that they have a
perspective like they openly admitted
they have a perspective right that's
different but as far as CNN goes I guess
the reason why I would consider that
more so I guess the reason why I would
consider that more so left-leaning or
like center-left which I still think is
right do you see what I'm saying yeah
like I still would consider that
right-wing I guess because of my
personal perspective is the the
difference in coverage and or how much
how much they've extended like how
critical they've been in previous
administrations like previous right-wing
administrations versus their coverage in
the way they've covered previous
left-leaning administrations or like
Barack Obama versus George Bush
obviously I can't make an equivalence to
Donald Trump versus Barack Obama because
that that's that would be considered
improper framing because Donald Trump is
a completely different demon in and of
itself and it is almost impossible not
to cover his like mishaps or ridiculous
statements that in many instances he
purposefully puts out there so he can
yeah I mean listen I get what you're
saying I would just understand that you
in a way kind of play the game when if
if the Trump administration attacks Free
Press in a way that no recent
administration has done and then CNN
correctly points out that like hey
that's kind of against everything that
the country is built on and then we say
hey you know what they do kind of lean
left like I think that we're were
perpetuating the problem if we do that
yeah no I agree
III definitely I do agree with that but
in the end of the day like I said look
they're they're framing or their
perspective more often than not leans
absolutely further to the right than I
would want in almost every instance and
that's what I was saying like they they
definitely perpetuate status quo
politics no matter what that is and the
status quo has leaned heavily towards
the right across the board over the past
couple decades not on social issues
obviously but certainly on on fiscal
policy and definitely and that's
precisely why I feel like they do
everything they can to kind of make sure
that that status quo was maintained
which is why I agree if they have a bias
I would still consider that to be more I
would still consider that to be more to
the right than what I would want agreed
yeah um and you see that like I guess
like Jake Tapper and whatnot always
really frustrate me because they they
consider themselves to be centrist but
like I know that they're conservative
you know what I mean like do we know
that so like he's you're saying Jake
Tapper personally is a right way I think
he definitely I mean I'm not saying he
would vote for Donald Trump because they
still have this like media or at least
major media still have this this
understanding that you know you can't
have any sort of personal political
opinion if you're going out there and
covering the news which I respect but I
don't think is like it has any basis in
reality every single person has a
political perspective that shouldn't
stop them from covering the news in a or
searching for the truth right or that
shouldn't stop them from
like holding people in positions of
power accountable but in the end of the
day like I think yeah Jake Tapper
certainly has more conservative leanings
yeah I just have no idea like I assume
Anderson Cooper is kind of left from
interviews I've heard him do on the
Howard Stern Show it seems pretty clear
that Don Lemon is more on the left than
the right like Wolf Blitzer I have no
idea what the guy's politics are I don't
think yeah I have no idea what politics
are I was exclusively a Frank Jake
Tapper because of like things he the
things he talks about a lot or like the
way he frames certain things on Twitter
for example like the way the way he
regards like Assata Shakur or he's the
guy who always is like well what about
keith Ellison like he's the one who's
like he's the one who's the first person
always asked well what about keith
Ellison
or or what about Farrakhan words like
who the [ __ ] is Farrakhan dude like why
are we like he's a yeah he's an
anti-semitic piece of [ __ ] but like is
Farrakhan or are you know are any like
any of his like Muslim followers going
out and committing anti-semitic hate
crimes or is it exclusively almost
exclusively they're like far-right
right-wingers and and neo-nazis were you
know taking it to the street and
screaming Jews will not replace us not
necessarily I don't know the answer to
that honestly I mean I know that it's
it's Nation of Islam historically does
have violence in its past but lately I
don't know I mean I sir looked at like
the breakdown of those incidents yeah my
point on it is that like I feel like
white nationalism is way more prevalent
on the right and also like anti-semitism
is a consequence of that because
anti-semitism is intertwined with with
racism in general for in you know in
most instances at least he's way more
prevalent on the right then like
anti-semitism has any form I on the left
I would say and maybe I agree with you I
agree with you that it's more right but
I've been talking a lot over the last
couple of anti-semitism
on the left as well and it comes from
actually it's kind of like a weird how
do I explain this like there's
anti-semitism on the left that comes
from the sort of attitude that like
listen Jews is an oppressed people Jews
is a discriminated against minority Jews
are doing fine in the United States
right now and there's kind of like this
implied lack of concern with
discrimination against Jews that I worry
about on the left and I've seen it in
many cases a piece about that I think he
was like claiming that anti-semitism
isn't a big deal I'm not one of those
people I don't think anyone anyone at
like TYT or I don't know I mean most of
the people I talk to you or not
necessarily that mindset but maybe I'm
incorrect I don't know yeah I'm not even
saying any but I'm just saying just
there is a contingent and I've seen it
in some cases with some of like the
college campus related stuff I've seen
it in even like here in Massachusetts
which is like super liberal on paper
there are some kind of weird things that
go on sometimes where I've seen in
different sort of like coalition
building things we're just like a group
of people have to decide stuff where
it's determined like okay we want to
give a voice to minorities minority
voices and disadvantaged voices to like
guide us and figure this thing out and
then people will be like oh okay yeah
like I'm Jewish and my family left
Eastern Europe because of discrimination
and and we're very concerned about the
climate right now and then the reaction
is like well hold on a second oh no like
when we say we want to give like
minority voices and people who are
oppressed and discriminated against we
didn't mean Jews like no you guys don't
you get you guys aren't part of that and
then you're like oh wait a second like
with the overwhelming majority of
religious hate incidents in the u.s or
against jews yeah
so so that's where i think the left has
a problem but i completely agree with
you that the majority of the problem is
on the right yeah no I
yeah I I don't like I said I don't know
a lot of like anti-semitism on the left
that I guess and look by the way you and
I I'm not necessarily sure on where you
stand as far as like
Zionism goes but maybe that's a again
like that's a point of I guess that's
like something that you and I might not
completely agree on but depending on
what your stances but outside of like a
conflation of anti-zionism is always
anti-semitism which I don't know what
your perspective is I'd love to hear it
I wouldn't I don't know I haven't really
like heard any serious like anti-semitic
messaging from the left at all with what
you're talking about as far as like oh
you should not have a voice in this
conversation because they're not an
oppressed minority I don't know it's
it's more does the idea that the Jewish
voices are part of the establishment
right that the Jewish voices are the
voices of privilege rather than
understanding that it's like one of the
most historically oppressed groups and
still like the primary target of
religious hate crimes it's more that
it's more understand okay yeah I don't
know but like I said it's yeah that's I
mean that's bad across the board and
that's not a good perspective to have
and it's also incorrect as you already
correctly pointed out if you look at
facts if you look at data it's the
overwhelming majority of hate crimes or
especially religiously targeted hate
crimes are still towards Jewish people
and and I think the reason for that like
a big part of the reason for that aside
from like historical oppression or even
as a consequence of historical
oppression is the the intersection of
racism and anti-semitism like I feel
like they are deeply intertwined with
one another because people oftentimes
like they they will say I'd like the
fascist roots of that that propaganda
comes from well Jewish people are the
ones were responsible for our
multicultural diverse society or
whatever the [ __ ] that the leading like
you know the leading anti-semitic
propaganda is usually it's like the
Frankfurt School and you and what's
what's really interesting to me what's
really crazy to me even is how
normalized this kind of anti-semitic
propaganda is in mainstream outlets like
the fact that the you know gates that
[ __ ] [ __ ] rep
I forget where he's from but he was even
on like the Sacha Baron Cohen show like
the fact that he put that out there that
tweet the Honduran Caravan tweet that
that then Donald Trump also retweeted
with the question like who's paying
these guys NGOs George Soros like George
Soros is an anti-semitic dog whistle it
definitely plays along with that same
fascist propaganda that is like Jews are
responsible for multiculturalism and
diversity ruining the the moral fabric
of Western society because they want to
import other people to what end we don't
know but that's like the grand like
fascist conspiracy right for sure yeah
and there's a lot of these I mean figure
there's a ton of so-called political
movements that are basically just covers
for racist or xenophobic ideology and
there's an interesting piece I read I
don't remember who wrote it but it's
basically talking about how even some of
the support for Trump's like NAFTA 2.0
thing that he did which will raise the
wages in Mexico for some of the auto
workers there that it's that there are
white separatists who like it because
they're thinking hey if the wages are
higher there then we'll have fewer brown
people here like there's all these on
undertones and undercurrents to these
political positions that relate to a lot
of the stuff you're talking about yeah I
I am genuinely of the mindset that there
are very few and maybe I'm incorrect and
and maybe you won't agree with me on
this but I'm genuinely other than mine
said that there are very few like actual
Republican voters who vote for the
Republican Party beyond the culture war
stuff and beyond like racial animus or
racial anxiety a fear of like
displacement or a fear of like yes that
is quote changing from a racial
perspective and that also encompasses
like even black people who are like I
don't mind that there's a white majority
because maybe I'm upper-middle class
under this current like white majority
ruled
system and if that were to be damaged in
any way maybe I'll lose my wealth like
you know what I'm saying or I mean I
think it's different for different
people but like you're identifying is
fear of losing the status they have or
think they have or think that they might
get some day and so like that was a big
thing in 2010 with the Tea Party
movement where all these voters were
fired up about the low tax for the rich
perspective of the Tea Party when it's
like listen you're not gonna benefit
from that statistically almost none of
you are ever gonna be rich enough to
benefit from that and it's the idea that
they might and of course statistically
it's like almost none of you will be but
they still support this stuff yeah I
mean I think that again the that's the
vehicle is just like racial animus
overall and I don't mean someone saying
someone saying like Hasan just said
millions of Obama voters voted for Trump
over race that's not what I said at all
I said it's like the racial like the
racial fears of so many like the
exclusive reason for a lot of a lot of
Republican voters for why they vote
Republican is not necessarily tax cuts
like I don't think they and even if that
is the case they don't necessarily
understand the long-term consequences of
of tax cuts or deregulation for example
these these like what like these broad
generalizations that people make as far
as like this is good deregulation is a
good thing it's like what I hear all the
time it's not it's not that or even if
it is that usually they don't really
understand the consequence of it but
they absolutely do understand the
consequence or the tangible impact that
that racial displacement might have on
them or racial displacement might have
on like what they understand is the
status quo and that's simply what I was
saying so like it's usually they like
the Tea Party people are a perfect
example like if they're if they're for
limited government why are they for
example Pro military spending or why
were they actively [ __ ] running
around with like really horrific figures
of like Barack Obama being lynched and
[ __ ] like if you're for limited
government like are you
why are you so anti Obama specifically
do you know what I mean
definitely yeah and the other
realization that they seem I've lost
hold on I'm losing you right now the
other realization you said yes that
sometimes the differences between the
Democratic and Republican candidates on
some of these issues big on that fiscal
stuff like for the most part it's just a
matter of like by how much does the
military budget increase yeah but by
what you know even the taxation
differences are really only materially
different for the very very richest
which mathematically barely exists like
of course they exist and they vote but
statistically they don't move elections
ya know I I would be very hard-pressed
to find out that if anyone genuinely
understands the consequence of like tax
cuts like in consequences as far as like
social programs and like social spending
going down or even like trying to cut
Social Security which were paying into
you right now if anyone was genuinely in
support of that and that's literally why
they're voting Republican do you see
what I'm saying absolutely and maybe I'm
incorrect maybe there's all these guys
genuinely love the the free market and
or whatever their understanding of the
free market is yeah I mean the other
thing also is like if you if you fall
for the aleko Bop socialist Democrat
socialist thing and then you might
perceive there to be much bigger
differences on economics than there
actually are but like the difference
between a fifteen dollar a twelve dollar
a ten dollar and an eight dollar minimum
wage is very significant for the people
who are earning those wages but like
it's not the difference between
socialism or not socialism yeah I mean
there are plenty of socialists who
believe that the welfare state is just
is just extending capitalism is like
giving capitalism a lifeline essentially
and that what we should be focusing on
is like the complete absolute
eradication of capitalism you know what
I mean
like there are plenty of left-leaning
let these people who feel that way
theoretically I understand where they're
coming from but you know ultimately
it's uh it's it's ridiculous especially
in the short term which by the way I
think again segues neatly into what I
want to talk about as far as like social
democracy versus not democratic
socialism which is like socialism in
general mom because I remember watching
some of your videos I think you did a
video on like describing the the almost
philosophical roots of socialism and
like where it comes from that was you
right you did like the Plato stuff yeah
which I fully agree with I think we have
like a very similar perspective when it
comes to that I just wanted to hear what
your perspective is on like why you
don't like do you do not ID you ideally
or idealistically do you oppose like
socialism or whatever your understanding
would be of socialism yes so I I am a
social democrat meaning that I think
that the best path for I rarely come
down on issues thinking that sort of
black/white solutions are the way to go
so for me social democracy makes sense
because you're maintaining a capitalist
system but you're saying that it has to
be a system that doesn't leave people
behind and it has to be a system that
prevents the abuses that our capitalist
system which is clearly broken suffers
from I don't think that we need to
change the ownership of business to make
it so that there is no more private
ownership of businesses or even property
as some like to go further and say we're
gonna socialized all of that I think
that we identify areas where profit is I
would argue immoral like health care for
example and we say we are gonna have a
society where if you want to be an
entrepreneur and your big thing is you
want to make a ton of money you can do
it but as your income climbs more and
more you're gonna have to pay more back
because you don't just make all that
money by yourself you're doing it on the
backs of a system that includes
infrastructure and police and education
and all this other stuff so as you make
more and more money you're gonna pay
more back in we're going to take a bunch
of that money we're gonna make it so the
people at the bottom get raised up so
you no longer have people that are
falling off
and and being losers in the game that is
capitalism and that to me is a system
that makes a lot of sense yeah um but
you're you also are aware again and and
this isn't like a gotcha thing this is
something I genuinely want to hear from
other like prominent Social Democrats
because I fully agree with you as far as
like no black and white answers to
anything and I also think that there's
an element of capitalism that that
speaks to individualism inside of every
single human being or or the
inevitability of like class hierarchy
right the complete destruction of like
class or the complete destruction of
class hierarchy to me especially with
our current understanding is is
completely it's impossible like I I do
feel that way because like there are
very easy arguments against that which
is like not all human beings are created
equal just look at like a soccer team
you know what I mean when you have like
you have to measure the output and and
pay people appropriately because of like
how much output that they have right
like sure that's made in like neo class
sure yeah so my my perspective always
still goes back to however the the fact
that like a lot of social democracies I
mean almost every single social
democracy is still not only built upon
like the the like history of
colonization and like violence as a
consequence of colonization but still
maintain social democracies because of
that I guess neo-colonial roots like
because of a consistent exploitation of
like natural resources from like African
countries for example in like France is
a good example of that I would even I'm
not fully certain on like what Norway
and like other more prominent social
democracies do in that regard
I could pull that up right now but I
feel like that's um the reason like the
reason why a lot of people I feel like
criticizing Marcus eases there's still
exploitation and you're saying like oh
well I understand that there's going to
be exploitation and I don't necessarily
have too big of a problem with it
No so I mean here's the thing so if you
socialized ownership of the means of
production and now you know every big
manufacturing company in the United
States is owned is as social ownership
and some of them still make cellphones
how does that necessarily stop the the
way that we get some of those conflict
minerals for cell phones from Africa
like it just it doesn't necessarily stop
that you know you're completely correct
and I think that we that's why i 100%
ally myself and i believe in like a
social democracy first and hopefully one
day get to a point where we are I guess
quote-unquote woke enough and that we
can focus on international solving like
international conflicts or solving
conflicts across other nations help
other nations develop in a non-violent
way and and ultimately lead to a
completely different economic structure
right that yeah I just don't see that
there's a guarantee that that happens
even if the United States becomes a
socialist country that's why these are
like international movements for the for
the most part about what kind of
transnational
Authority would make that happen and
isn't it don't you need something
extraordinarily heavy-handed an
authoritarian to enforce that and to
make that a reality
and what doesn't seem to really align
with the ideas of socialism yes the
democratic principles from within would
like it's not it's not like a new world
order
like singular unit I don't like I said I
don't know what the what the best
possible outcomes is precisely why I I
don't like advocate for one thing over
the other and people get upset at me for
this sometimes I just think that there
are certain elements like as far as
profit and the way we understand profit
that could absolutely be closer to I
guess that's like one of the
democratizing the workplace is like one
of the places where I get more Marxist
in my perspective but as far as like the
elimination of profit motive
in certain industries girls like you and
I already are in agreement and I think
in a country like America that is hyper
capitalist
and and we're you know economic
inequality is is so apparent because of
that we like Social Democrats are
absolutely like reasonable and and make
make socialism more mainstream
regardless they're definitely yeah I was
gonna say which is like even even to the
socialist I would just say listen like
the next step no matter what is not so
so join the fight for social democracy
join the fight for a mixed economy that
works better for everybody once we get
that if you still are pushing for social
those who still want to go to socialism
after we get a real functioning social
democracy then that's a debate that we
can have and we'll see what idea wins
out i I do I absolutely do agree with
that like that was my that was going to
be that's always been my perspective is
like a slower and and people obviously
don't agree with that and like a lot of
people on the Left have different
opinions on that mine is I am of that
mindset where like Social Democrats
should be the reasonable Center you know
what I mean
sure Oh like the the the way we regard
like neo liberals now are corporate
Democrats now like Social Democrats
should be that a reasonable center where
people are talking and and for example
that's part of the reason and I maybe
you agree with me on this is part of the
reason why there are plenty of people on
the Left that I disagree with I would
say like Lenin is Stalinist they were
like or even tanki's for example who I
what's the difference between a tanky
and a Stalin tanky is a Stalinist tank
is just like a it's violent means to a
potential utopian end is acceptable as
long as like we have full communism and
all that I have a video that we're
publishing over the weekend that's on
show about how I don't that I sort of
explained to people what is meant by
tanki but I also don't think we should
use the term because it is a pejorative
and you probably lose more people but I
have also like you identified this sort
of stall and this Leninist left and
that's not that's not my wing of the
left for sure yeah
it's but what I was going to say is like
in order to
reshift the Overton Window back to a
place where it is comfortable I think we
should be allowing those people have a
voice at the table as well because no
matter how radical that perspective is
to someone like even yourself because
you you have a difference in opinion
there even though tanki's I would
consider like authoritarian left or even
like like conservative left almost they
I
I still believe that they should help in
establishing or they should help in in
pulling the the conversation back to the
left and make people like yourself seem
more reasonable in comparison and the
thing that happens but the thing that
has happened on the right is for example
like anarcho-capitalist so the way we
look at the way we view like right
leaning libertarians in this country and
how or or the Tea Party as you mentioned
these are these are extremely further to
the right like these are really really
right-wing political perspectives that
are of course they don't have a history
um because it has never existed like
anarcho-capitalism or even full
capitalism has never existed in the way
that like these people promote it but
they are as far as theory goes they are
almost as damaging if not even more
damaging than then like tanki's or
Stalinist do you see what I'm saying
it depends what conversation you're
trying to have right so I think I agree
with you that if we're trying to have a
conversation based on like the
predominant political worldviews right
now and kind of like work within that to
figure out how we can improve this then
yeah absolutely i mean those ideology
most toxic elements of like the current
american political system for sure i
think if you want to have a conversation
about what society should look like kind
of like in the absence of these
right-wing bomb throwers who will just
get Cal up and make it impossible to
even have to be I would I would want to
think hard about what benefit there
is from having like Stalinists play a
role in that discussion beyond just kind
of like understanding that we don't want
that so I'd want to think a little more
about that
well my yeah my perspective is like the
way I see it is you regard them as as
the right who have successfully somehow
been able to create this like larger
umbrella by by like focusing exclusively
on like certain things that every
Republicans every Republican loves
they've been able to bring in like a
narco anarcho-capitalists like and caps
and and and beyond under there like
under under the Republican umbrella I
guess and that has also played a part in
my mind maybe I'm incorrect but that has
also played a part in like moving the
conversation the more extreme part the
the more extreme elements of the right
have been able to successfully
successfully bring in legislators and
and successfully been able to bring in
representatives into Congress into
positions of power within the Republican
within the Republic and and that has
successfully whether we like to whether
we agree with that or not but that has
successfully been able to push like I
said the overall Overton Window firmly
the right and the reason why I mentioned
this is because like even when Donald
Trump for example even when Donald Trump
tried to push for like Obamacare repeal
without a replacement if you remember
the freedom caucus which is
predominantly made of these people right
the freedom caucus had a lot of issues
with like the way Planned Parenthood was
being funded or like what health care
well what would be still covered under
like a new health care plan and they
were forced to essentially listen to the
more extreme the more extreme side of
their party because otherwise they would
be gridlocked even though they had
majority and that kind of that that like
I would obviously love to have I would
obviously love to have like like-minded
individuals on the left but I do think
that more extreme more extreme people
more radical elements with
and within the left could potentially
push for more radical politicians or at
least like more reasonable politicians
that are further to the center than they
are and then like I said bring about a
new understanding within our within
contemporary politics that's like closer
to the middle yeah I get what you're
saying I just think that the reason that
this is I think Alan is a failure of
actually being left like I don't think
that type of authoritarian communism is
actually left-wing I think it's of the
left so then the question is do you want
to need to be situation to break
gridlock by conceding stuff to Stalinist
I don't that's just not what I would
want to that's not the situation that we
want to be in yeah oh but yeah you keep
getting cutting you keep cutting out I I
think I heard what you were saying
though I'm sorry I got a few minutes
left I don't know if you wanted to
assume things it is Halloween or not
yeah I forgot yeah I was gonna ask you
what your perspective is on like
cultural appropriation versus cultural
appreciation and like do you have like
what do you what kind of like rubs you
the wrong way or are you like an
absolutist I guess when it comes to this
sort of expression what's your
personality I'm not an absolutist I
think that the last thing the left needs
to do is come up with a list of costumes
that are okay and costumes that are not
okay basically my view is the following
you you do so thinking back to that
negging clip which was her last her last
morning show apparently she's going to
be doing on NBC I think it might have
been Melissa rivers who made the comment
or maybe it was somebody else on the
panel I don't remember now basically
just like you have to apply some common
sense and you do have to think about
what the motivations are for a
particular costume so is it wrong for
any white person to dress up as a black
person no there's nothing objectively
wrong with that and you shouldn't put it
on a list of stuff you're not allowed to
do does blackface specifically have this
particular dark past
that we should understand and then
realize what it is that we're doing if
we put that on then yeah we should do
that you know it's sort of it's sort of
like identity politics for me where I
feel like the right has Strom and
identity politics in a way that does
exist on the left but it's not like the
main problem left we should just have a
nuanced approach which is like listen
identity is not a trump card that lets
you say nobody else's voice matters or
to decide whose voice can be heard and
which one can but we got to understand
that people's identity is relevant and
we should listen to how one's identity
impacts their place in the world it's
the same thing with the costumes right
like there's no list of approved and
unapproved costumes things are context
dependent but understand what it is that
you're doing when you wear one of these
costumes understand you know there's no
situation where like the costume version
of that caricature that the anti-semitic
like hand grubbing big-nose jew there's
no version of that costume that that
would sort of be like acceptable right
like it invariably refers to something
very specific use common sense that's it
it's like it's like give me one example
of of the n-word that you have to you
have to wear you have to say the n-word
to save a life or it's a part of like
productive discourse like you have to
say because if you're if you're trying
to find like theoretical situations
where like in these like weird
hypotheticals that you draw up where you
have to wear like an anti-semitic
costumery where you have to wear a black
face like then then you've already lost
you know what I mean like that's not
it's just it makes no you know it makes
it makes no sense what so yeah I mean I
think a good example is like dressing up
like in an SS like a Nazi outfit for a
party okay so like is it should that be
off should that be on some list where
you're not allowed to do that no are
most people going to see that and unless
you sort of sympathize with the ideology
and are missing about the era of the
Nazis are you gonna react and be like
that's really cool that seems like a
completely reasonable costume choice
most people are going to
I didn't think you couldn't have gone as
one of the guys from Ghostbusters or
something else like what what are we
really gaining from you dressing up the
Nazi you just got apply common sense or
like what your what your perspective is
I don't know as far as like humor goes
or as far as like you know the
boundaries of like policing jokes and
whatnot goes like I think there was a
time when like the most outrageous humor
was tried by every single person where
like everyone was like insult comedy
that sort of stuff like everyone was
trying to say is like as crazy stuff as
they possibly could but now we know for
a fact that like actual crypto fascists
are utilizing the freedom of speech
channels to like put their it put their
opinions out there and it's no longer a
meme or it's no longer just a joke it's
like it's very real and you
inadvertently if you're a part of this
group if these group of people there
you're like I'm just joking dude like
I'm just [ __ ] joking and you're a
part of this group then you're you know
you either willingly or inadvertently
without realizing or supporting like
real fascism and that's yeah and we're
seeing the consequences of that that's
like genuinely damaging the moral fabric
of society but it's also like genuinely
hurtful and and violent and has like
seriously violent outcomes when when
these people are like showing support to
that sort of stuff and the other the
only other thing I would say also is
that immediately when you start talking
about costumes and what's sort of like
culturally or socially acceptable and
what isn't very quickly there will
people who start making arguments about
censorship which is you don't have to
put certain costumes on a list but if
you make the consequences bad enough
you're going to basically be punishing
people for their speech or forcing them
to self-censor because wearing a costume
is a type of speech you are free to wear
whatever costume you want but you're not
free from the consequences of that and
society and culture will react to that
costume that's their speech and that's
okay also as long as no one's committing
a crime
no I I know that's it's it's hilarious
when yeah exactly it's hilarious when
people are like well um you know these
people are protesting me for for you
know wearing blackface well it's like
what did you think was gonna happen you
[ __ ] baby you can't like that's a
speech you can't use the levers of power
to also then like force these people to
or you can't use the government to
silence the opposition just because
they're against you because that is also
inherently anti-free speech yes anyway
exactly all right I don't want to take
up any more of your time I feel like you
got to go but thank you so much for
coming on and also if there's anything
you want to plug like give us your you
know what's your what's your Twitter and
all that sort of stuff it's follow me on
Twitter at D Pakman I've been mixing it
up with lately check out my website
David Pakman
divi pakman.com patreon membership I
mean we got also you know how it is but
too much stuff is that a good place to
like figure out what all your stuff is
like yeah I'm gonna spam it in the chat
right now everybody go to check out
david pakman.com and then you know he's
a patreon on there it's starting at $5 a
month he has a show called the David
Pakman show
he's a podcast so you know get in there
um show David some love and even thank
you so much for coming on thanks for
having me any time all right awesome
talk to you soon dude